hi hi le tout le monde est bienvenu
quest tag l'épisode 7 wonders de fox
elle explique comment tes parents
tombaient au monde parce qu'il te manque
à tétouan et tu as les orteils
l'écoutent peut-être comme ça non ou
peut-être pas tu sais mon géant kiwi
pardonnez moi
d'ailleurs c'est très pratique pour
espérer chez soi revêtus de sport car je
trouve que un peu musclée au niveau des
bras moi je trouve que pas muscle au
niveau des bras car - intersport à la
config de ton ancien pc était plutôt bon
tu lui as tu fait pour qu'il te déteste
arrête de bugs et là tu es sûr tu peux
faire le malin avec moi jusqu'au bout
ok c'est quand ton anniversaire alors je
réponds à la question des primes pour la
simple et bonne raison que ça fait plus
d'une semaine que tous les jours je
reçois je sais pas combien de messages
me souhaitant un bon anniversaire
sauf que cet anniversaire bon
anniversaire c'est lundi prochain donc
le 27 janvier
et j'aurais 18 ans plus tôt blanches
brunes et ben moi j'aime bien les deux
donc plutôt world
pourquoi tu tombes sur ce alors que tu
es seul dans des vidéos qui t'a dit que
j'étais seul dans mes vidéos qui fait
quoi du manga
l'explication il fait quoi lui mon gars
as tu des animaux de compagnie ouais
j'ai juste un chat s'appelle lola qui
est extrêmement extrêmement vénère
actuellement qui veut peut-être
l'attaqué j'aime bien mettre sa patte
sur le bouche des gens as tu déjà fait
du judo en fait tu encore si oui tu
étais qu'elle ceinture perso je suis
ceinture bleue verte watch en effet un
monde du judo j'ai des ceintures jaunes
blanches et je me souviens qu'en
dernières années on avait quand même un
bon petit nouveau parce que le prof me
faisait faire ça donne quoi que ça
marche
j'avais 6 ans et demi voilà bon j'en ai
fait je me serais peut-être tu préfères
real chinois ou japonais vietnamien est
ce que le sap dans ton cul dans
l'épisode 1 date limite ça fait mal pas
tant que vous ne retire pas y avait un
problème
bon gros café à la tu fait de ton ancien
fauteuil on a volé
je sais que chez marvel thor super héros
préférés d'iron man mais chez dc comics
bonnes questions alors moi c'est green
lantern
parce que déjà je trouve que le délire
avec la foule s'était massée un peu
sympa ça change a eu des mecs super
stock hyper musclé que celle qu'on voit
souvent en petits tas héros et puis
deuxième chose son costume est
totalement ridicule mais qui a conçu ce
machin si tu casses un truc super
important tu fais quoi eh ben ça
m'arrivait ya quelques jours et ça s'est
passé comme ça et voilà les gens c'est
déjà la fin de ce costume d'homme
épisode 7 j'espère que ça vous aura plu
je m'excuse pour la qualité sonore la
vidéo qui est pas loin d'être
dégueulasse qui est dégueulasse d'accord
il va falloir je me rachète d'un micro
et du bateau parce que là ça ne va pas
du tout en tout cas je vous souhaite un
très bon week-end et puis je vous dis à
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo dimanche
soir posez moi vos questions dans les
commentaires sur deux mondes pis
et ta mère
tara
à